Let's walk through the code you wrote to complete the mapper function.
First, we create an array data, which splits each row of data on the comma.
If the length of the data array is not equal to 12,
which is what we expect given our aadhaar data.
Or the first entry is equal to registrar,
which would indicate that this is the header row.
We continue on the the next row.
Otherwise, we print the district and
the number of aadhaar generated separated by a tab.
Now, let's talk about the reducer function.
Recall that our reducer function will consume the key value pairs emitted by
our mapper.
So we create and array data for every single line,
which will essentially be of length of two containing the key and the value.
Note that we split on the tab, which we input into the output of our mapper.
If for some reason data is less than or greater than length two, we continue on.
There's something wrong with this key value pair and we shouldn't process it.
Next, we set this key and
count equal to the key and number of aadhaar generated in data.
Recall that the reducer receives the key value pair sorted by key.
So if this is a new key, let's submit the final key value pair.
The key and the total number of aadhaar generated, separated by a tab.
Then let's set aadhaar generated equal to zero.
Otherwise, let's add the number of aadhaar generated in
this particular key value pair to the total number of aadhaar generated for
this key and let's continue onto the next value.
We include this last if clause for the last key in our data.
Because there's no next key after the last key.
If we didn't have this, we would not admit a key value pair for
the final key in our intermediate data.
So here after we've done all this other processing up here, we just say for
the last key, hey, let's make sure we emit the key value pair.